même si chacun va faire son travail je
te propose de tutoyer ça te va ok mon
amour moi je te connais pas donc je vais
vous voyez dans ce film merci beaucoup
est-ce que vous pouvez dire salut Lilou
s'il vous plaît
on envoie des émissions ou honnêtement
on met 6 personnes dans une maison je
suis désolé de le dire mais des fois il
y a des culs d'huîtres dans les maisons
c'est on est en train de de fracturer
une génération en leur disant mais c'est
comme ça qu'il faut être c'est grave
c'est dangereux c'est tout ce que vous
voulez c'est très dangereux je vous ai
préparé une tenue un peu sexy et tout on
va se mettre dans l'ambiance et on va se
donner à fond
on peut détester les influenceurs comme
on déteste je sais pas il y en a qui
détestent ces policiers il y en a qui
détestent pour très bien mais sans
sombrer dans le déchaînement de haine
déchaînement de haine qui a été quand
même déclenchée par rapport Booba moi ça
m'amuse quand Bouba nous donne des
leçons et qui derrière
pousse finalement des des jeunes femmes
a subir un cyber-harcèlement que que
personne ne doit subir enfin on a le
droit d'être là
franchement je suis pas très à l'aise
c'était la vérité
à chaque fois
c'est pas toi qui va nous dire ce qu'on
a le droit de dire ou pas dire à ce
micro merci
inutile
mais là sincèrement il faut le dire il
faut dire qu'il y a du cyber à
harcèlement et que les années alors
c'est quoi ça
qu'est-ce qu'il y a toi arrête de parler
pourquoi tu parles
je te le jure tu sais pourquoi je
m'énerve après toi parce que tu sais que
je t'aime beaucoup mais je pense que tu
es vraiment c'est des gens comme toi qui
font qu'aujourd'hui on est dans la dans
la situation dans laquelle on est tué tu
ne sais pas prendre les décisions tu dis
n'importe quoi tu veux faire plaisir à
tout le monde et quand on veut faire
plaisir à tout le monde on fait plaisir
à personne tu n'as pas de règle tu tu
voilà tu ne sais pas mettre de un cadre
c'est un acteur extraordinaire mesdames
messieurs et je pèse mes mots jouer un
prix Nobel de littérature un écrivain de
cette manière là alors que
je connais ton niveau scolaire et
tu vois
de la mobilitudes
[Musique]
d'être un peu à contre-courant en
parlant de ce monsieur qui est le
cinéaste qu'il était bon moi c'était pas
ma tasse de thé mais surtout l'homme
qu'il était qui a pas été très très
bienveillant pour la pour ma communauté
pour les Juifs en général et pour Israël
en particulier en fait tu veux que je te
dise un mytho parce que tout simplement
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas décollement de racine que tu
as eu c'est un décollement de cerveau
vous allez au dialogue de Bercy là non
non
je peux pas par exemple je suis pas une
région c'est mieux
alors on m'a dit un truc quand même vous
vous jouez à un jeu de cartes que je ne
connais pas qui s'appelle l'Enculette
l'enculé mais c'est quoi ce jeu j'ai
jamais entendu parler de ça alors c'est
un jeu de tarot et on ne va jouer que
avec les atouts mais c'est un jeu 100%
breton ou non c'est mondialement connu
l'Enculette attention
[Musique]
me regardez pas comme ça
oh non vous pensez pas à ça vous pensez
pas ça qui se termine par un S ah bah si
ah non bah non
voici la première statue que mon
grand-père a découvert en 1946 elle
était couchée par terre mais là cette
particularité d'avoir vraiment une forme
humaine avec cette tête qui ressort par
rapport aux épaules quand l'ouvrier a vu
cette pierre lui il disait c'est parfait
là regarde on met le la corde autour il
pourra l'accrocher directement pour
faire la clôture mais mon grand-père lui
ce qu'il a vu c'est vraiment une
représentation humaine si ça se trouve
c'est ça pourquoi vous voulez pas
proposer
j'ai une réputation 4 minutes
on verra après c'est peut-être ça
franchement tu sais chez nous il faut
oser parfois
on a eu bien pire que ça de pas avoir
touché le bon on verra tout à l'heure
moi je ne m'arrête de jouer que sur une
victoire oui il faut toujours s'arrêter
sur l'enculer quand on a gagné voilà ça
ce sera l'image du jour ok c'est fait
c'est gravé dans le marbre